welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday from sports teams to theater
productions high schools are full of
extracurricular activities for students
to pursue but one after-school program
you may not know about is growing in
popularity it involves varsity teams
competing not on the gridiron but over
the grill iron
Mireya Villarreal has the story what's
Texas brisket for us chef Mike Erickson
is using barbeque to teach some big life
lessons in this small Texas town
are we done developing flavor no because
we still are gonna apply heat at Burnet
High School students cook in a
state-of-the-art kitchen
worth a quarter of a million dollars to
create what some would consider the holy
grail of Texas grilling you don't have
to be the biggest kid you don't have to
be the smartest kid you don't have to be
the richest kid and you could go to the
Houston Livestock rodeo or our state
championship and win and for some young
people that's it's a dream this would be
a competition style notice everyone in
here is part of the underdogs a high
school varsity barbecue team won the
regional championship last year here in
Texas you know everybody always says
football is king but barbecue is pretty
high up there and so what's the level of
respect that you get when you guys walk
around at the barbecue team the reaction
that I most often get is we have a
barbecue team in just three years the
number of varsity teams across Texas has
grown to a hundred and two dishes like
brisket ribs and beans are judged on
taste texture and presentation and the
competition is as hot as their grills
the team placed 11th at their annual
staid Y tournament after doing practice
runs like this all year long this is
really good and yet really juicing what
makes the perfect group for you I mean
flavors big but the texture of it if
it's like rubbery mm-hmm so big no for
you is it just about barbecue or is it a
little bit deeper than that
I enjoy our teamwork and the stuff that
we do as a barber
team it's a lot of fun I get the same
feel as with football the difference is
it's more personal most of this team is
made up of seniors planning to attend
different colleges so right now they're
savoring every moment together for CBS
this morning Saturday the day of getting
out Burnett Texas football and barbecue
in Texas the motto here come eat our
homework
[Laughter]